I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right one of the the things I
really enjoy talking to Muhammad about
uh which I also want to ask you about is
yeah uh Mohammed described when he was a
young man and and how he was feeling
unsure about who he was and what his
purpose was yeah and that's how he he
found well he already you're already
religious but obviously that was what
made you uh more certain of it yeah was
there a moment for you personally that I
I wasn't a Muslim so this is this might
be interesting I came to Islam 10 years
ago wow so my dad's atheist and he has a
very strong hate a passion like he
doesn't like Islam do you have conflict
with him for that oh yeah for the past
10 years when I'm in Conflict obviously
in our religion that Allah says in the
Quran that after you show your obedience
to God Almighty you're worshiping him to
be obedient to your parents so if these
parents can be Muslim or not Muslim so
she have to be obedient towards them
this is something that sadly is
forgotten in our times but there's times
where like I've had the times where my
dad slapped me in my face he kicked me
out the house and I know that's not good
yeah
I'm not gonna lie so the thing is it's
it's uh when that happened obviously um
I know he doesn't come from an evil
place but he has this perception of
Muslims and Islam and so he's scared for
me so that's why he was he tried
different approaches tried to use
intellectual arguments okay it didn't
work okay put some pressure on didn't
work or maybe just going through a phase
let him be didn't work so and he was
like and I was becoming more and more
religious so he didn't like that so but
now he's better you know it's your
religion and your parents you know your
love yes I do but like our love to our
religion is greater and that might sound
strange to you but uh you know our
vision to uh a love to our Lord and the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
greater than our love it should be
greater should I say it's something that
someone can say easily it's not easy
easy said than done but the thing is it
it it obviously it breaks you apart to
know that you know your dad you know is
hostile and honestly you want the best
for him in this life and in the
Hereafter that we believe in so you have
your ups and downs but my mom's always
been there till like when I used to pray
I used to pray secretly he never knew
what was it that sort of Drew you to the
religion was there a person okay so to
me personally for my story like for
example I come from a start like before
when I used to live in London I lived in
another most of my life I was involved
in gangs and stuff like just fighting
your typical just like fighting game
into fights and all that kind of stuff
um so then afterwards what happens I
used to get into a lot of trouble here I
got caught walking with a knuckle duster
um so a undercover officer sorry and I
was I was literally playing around with
it so they stopped me they arrested me
and then my dad heard that he said look
you'll come in he had a business outside
of London he said to come with me I
lived at a place called Grimsby Grimsby
yeah yes I believe it's one of the most
racist towns in London I mean in the UK
but when I moved there my whole
lifestyle changed it changed from
fighting gangs to partying clubbing
girls all that kind of stuff oh wow so
yeah
everything no girls for you
I guess yeah and I'm not proud of it no
but
the fascinating thing for me is
obviously when I was talking to Muhammad
it was it was his struggle to avoid the
lifestyle in the first place but once
you've tasted it yes to then turn your
back on it it's almost potentially
harder in some regards yes yes so so how
was there a moment where it got really
bad or you know where you felt like you
hit a bit of a rock bottom to be honest
when I was living that lifestyle there
were certain things that started to make
sense to me like I had like this I
always thought I always believed in a
higher power I thought religion or
man-made to control the masses I thought
I've got no time for that I don't
believe in that I believe there's some
kind of a Powerhouse that's basically
what I am just so you know it's fine I
was there I was there a long time ago
you know it was a guy I know who's a
scientist who he works on um human blood
okay and that's what made him religious
wow which is so strange yes you're a
scientist you're supposed to be odds
with religion and he went when I looked
at Blue under a microscope I see in a
design yeah and my brain was like
there's a Creator yes a boom that was it
so the thing is when I had that
realization I forget there is a Creator
but if that Creator exists then why did
he put me here it's impossible for me
for him to be a creator that has is
purposeless crater yeah there must be a
purpose and I thought to myself okay
there must be a True Religion out there
somewhere we'll give the example if
you're in a train and or a plane or
whatever and you've got everything you
want on that train but at one moment
you're going to but hold on a second who
put me on this plane where the hell is
this plane going it's all fun and good
but where am I going and why am I here
so this question made me realize well
hold on a second that's when I opened
the Bible
um you know I opened the Bible I've read
the Bible a lot I spent three and a half
years looking into comparative religion
and was this in your mind of I'm going
to select one out of these oh well okay
so you did that yes I said one of these
has to be from God which one I don't
know but I'm just going to start my
journey but obviously the concept of one
God resonated with me because I was like
multiple girls so who which God did that
God created could there has to be one
ultimate power there can't be two this
is a contingent thing so this thing
relies on something else for its own
existence right so we have three kinds
of existence correct me when I fluff it
here okay because I learned this about
this is my teacher in this yeah so
basically we have impossible existence
possible existence and necessary
existence impossible existence is can we
have a triangle Circle we can't what
does this okay so we were left with two
things possible existence and necessary
existence this is a possible existence
this could be any other way this could
have not existed right so therefore what
we see is that within our universe for
example there are contingent things
these are things that rely on something
else for the Existence be our planet be
the Sun be the galaxies and be it our
universe but what we see is exactly even
us yeah so what we see is you cannot
have an infinite regress of dependent
things I've been doing my research and
it was just a fascinating uh to hear you
guys talking I used to live this
lifestyle it didn't bring me happiness
and I believe a lot of people that live
this life
okay all this kind of stuff okay so the
thing is I really wish we could have
like a cut in the edit right now and
just have him like close to it
so the thing is that lifestyle I
realized it does not bring me happiness
and it will never bring happiness
because the way God Almighty has created
us is that Allah says in the Quran you
wouldn't you will only find happiness in
his in the members of God Almighty okay
and if you forget his remembrance you
live a depressed life meaning what you
we are all we all want some kind of a
purpose and then what happens is the way
we are created we have something called
the fitra our innate disposition we are
created as if like imagine somebody
programmed a robot to only find not that
robot can feel anything but with a
specific thing by giving I don't know
argument said giving it a hat just it's
just that's its most happiness when it's
most happy the thing is here is that
anything that I chased I was never happy
anything I used to do bodybuilding I
used to go boxing I used to all this
kind of stuff and there was always
I don't want to embarrass you so the
thing is here is that I realize that it
doesn't bring me happiness got a
question on my life based on what you're
saying please so I drink a lot yeah
especially in the last seven days and I
smoke weed and you know and I've
certainly uh I've not um not exactly
been more strict guy with myself yeah
and and it doesn't bring me happiness
necessarily although in that moment it
certainly feels all right but you've got
the hangover and whatever else yes you
guys have obviously avoided that or at
least you you have for a long time and
you have recently
but you know when life gets a bit too
much and and you know you need advice or
and and sometimes our Consciousness just
needs an escape yes how do you combat
that what do you do we we escape the god
that's what we do we we escape the the
thing here is this alcohol
um weed women men opposite gender
nothing is going to make you happy
period
accept because what I'm saying is the
way we are programmed look you we all
eat food okay you're not gonna go and
drink something that's poisonous you're
not gonna go and have bad food you know
why because your stomach will reject it
and you will vomit it this is a physical
low God Almighty put in place that when
you eat something which is not good for
you in your body the stomach
automatically takes it out the soul is
the same way the soul wants the
remembrance of God and I'll come to what
that means when you give it girls like
this is what I used to do okay I have
girlfriends not happy cause not happy
money not happy holidays not happy and I
was thinking what does it want the soul
wants the soul soul food you know
literal food which is what the
remembrance of its Lord that's what is
connected That's Where It's At Home
truly and if you look into the Quran God
Almighty always says that you will
return back to me let me ask you a
question where are you most comfortable
in your life for example
um is this Bible do you live here yeah
you live here okay this is your house
yeah you know like they say sweet home
home sweet home yeah the house is the
place where you're most comfortable you
can walk naked literally it's your place
your space you're gonna do whatever you
yeah so the thing is he uh at home you
are the most comfortable yeah now God
Almighty for us is our most Comfort is
when we return back to him that is where
Comfort that's why when we come to this
life and we're like why do some things
go smooth why is things not perfect
because you are not home you are not
home so what we're seeing is that when
you realize and I came to that
realization I thought to myself I'm
chasing this lifestyle and I used to
always give this example I used to go
clubbing them I used to wear a specific
jumper but I believe that looks really
handsome like I believe that you know
yeah
so the thing is I I used to wear
specific clothes work extra hours to
live a certain lifestyle I came to the
realization I thought to myself before I
came to Islam I thought to myself these
are my masters that jumper that I hate
wearing but I worry because I look good
in it just as a woman who wears these
this much heels even though she's
uncomfortable in her her fear he was a
bleeding she still does it why because I
look good in it so I thought to myself
please sorry I interrupt you I watched a
lot of new videos about Kim Kardashian
that's kind of talking about literally
about the way she presents herself in
how how misguided she is well she's
willing to eat poo just to look young
and I mean if that's not enslavement
what I don't know what enslavement is so
the point I'm trying to say is this here
that we are bound to be Enslaved the
stuff here and another philosopher I've
got the reference here that Google
um man is Born Free by instructors
everywhere is the same guy yeah let's
remember that yeah man is Born Free but
in shackles everywhere exactly did you
choose your name did you choose your
parents did you she's your sister did
you choose the uh did you choose the way
you look no you didn't so nobody can
come and say we're free we are not we
are Shackled somewhere now what does
Allah say in the Quran he says have you
seen the one who has one master and
multiple Masters would you rather be
enslaved to multiple things or one thing
that is deserving of your worship to me
I came to the realization I said hold on
a second if God Almighty exists which I
believe he does and I found it through
is Islam and Islam to be the truth I
would rather be enslaved to him rather
than being enslaved to my jumper to the
opposite gender to the money to living a
lifestyle that is fake and I found my
true Freedom when I enslaved myself to
the one who created me because I believe
he's deserving of worship and I believe
he created me when I die all your
friends
that you have me and back then yeah best
believe how are they going to cry for
that I bet you they're not gonna cry for
one day they're gonna forget you they're
gonna back by you they're gonna talk ill
of you yeah and I came to a realization
that I have to prove myself to nobody
but God and I I swear to God when I
accepted Islam it's as if a mountain
went off my shoulder you know why
because I didn't care about who thinks
what of me oh what card do you drive
brother drive Toyota Prius yes
oh I'm shy if somebody sees me oh I need
to wear branded I don't care and this is
where true happiness is found this is
what I believe when I talked about the
soul your soul wants the remembrance of
God and what do we do we give alcohol
weed opposite gender whatever it may be
and then the Soul is saying I don't want
it I reject it I reject it I reject it
and with the moment you give it the
correct food it Embraces it and that's
where you find happiness that's why I
realize I know why I'm here I know where
I'm going I know my purpose and I know
where I want to be and if you don't have
that in your life it's like the wind on
a windy day you're like a leaf wherever
the wind takes you you just end up there
the thing is Allah says in the Quran we
send the smaller Calamity to divert a
bigger Calamity the bigger Calamity is
that we believe there is Judgment Day
there is hellfire there is heaven and
the god that we worship is not a God
that wants to flow people in this sense
yes this this scenario that I'm yes is
revealing who's really loyal exactly but
is it a Calamity yes it is but it might
be a Calamity of people who don't have
my back exactly but what does that show
you it shows you again that nobody is
there for you truly except the one who
created you I think you're both coming
from the same place and I really respect
that which is Islam
also being selfish exactly giving and I
think that's something that we can all
collect on because for me personally
while I'm not a spiritual guy in that
sense at least yet uh mental health is
my thing and that's what my uh what I
want to help and leave behind
um and yeah I find I've really enjoyed
this guys honestly thanks for your time